so the mayor of brooklyn center has a
brilliant idea about police reform a lot
of a lot of brilliant ideas about police
reform are going around especially on
the left right now
before we get to the mayor actually
rashida talib um
one one member of the squad said
a couple days ago announced that we
should abolish police
and abolish incarceration okay so it's
not an exaggeration to say that
that she wants to free every prisoner in
jail right now in prison you should
there's no incarceration
let them all out of jail nobody goes to
jail
so the child molesters and child rapists
uh they get to
get out of jail that's what rashida
talib wants to free
every child rapist from prison that is
an accurate statement
um now i mean it is it is sort of
interesting in in her case
that she says she wants to abolish
incarceration abolish the police
um did i'll go back and check does
anyone remember rashida talib
speaking out against the incarceration
of the protesters on january 6 at
capitol hill
what did she have to say about that
because
they're being hunted down and thrown in
prison
sometimes getting lengthy prison
sentences uh or or you know
charges that carry lengthy prisoner
sentence is put on their head
and has rasheeda to she wants to abolish
incarceration shouldn't she should she
be speaking out against that no i don't
think so
because of course when she says abolish
incarceration we know
that that she means that in a very
selective way
like she wants to abolish incarceration
for certain people
it's not even just it's not that she
wants to abolish incarceration
for certain crimes no it's for certain
people shouldn't go to jail no matter
what they do
that's her view the mayor of uh brooklyn
center has a view that
is nearly as crazy and let's listen to
what he has to say
uh and uh make sure that you know we sit
down and
and go through it and and see how we can
implement
uh i i don't believe that officers need
to necessarily
uh have weapons uh
you know uh every time they they're
they're making a traffic stop
or engaged in uh
situations that don't necessarily call
for
uh for weapons we know that there are
other many other jurisdictions or even
around the world where
that is not you know necessarily the
case it's not needed
you know i don't believe that
construction workers
necessarily need hard hats
uh you know i don't get i think they
look stupid in the hard hats it's silly
what do you guys you're on your
construction's like how often does
something fall on your head right it
doesn't happen all that often
you don't need a hard hat all the time i
mean i'm not on the construction site
and i need the people on the
construction site to build stuff so that
i can you know
take advantage of the things they build
but i'm going to sit off on my couch
and drink a beer and start start giving
my opinion about the safety measures
taken by construction workers
look at that when they're stupid hard
hats
is the exact same thing kind of thing
here now he's he's standing off on the
sideline and saying
they don't need guns what do they need
that for
yeah attract any any cop knows that a
traffic stop can turn
fatal for the officer in a split second
and what this this happens a lot
you know you can go online and find
video you're not going to find a lot of
news articles about this kind of thing
because the media doesn't report on that
but if you if you go and look you can
find and you want to see it
you can find video uh dash cam footage
and so forth
officers in a normal traffic stop you
know enforcing
a traffic regulation next you know
they're getting shot at
now the the mayor of brooklyn center his
view
is that if if you start if a cop
is getting shot at during traffic stop
well you just have to die that's all
just die i mean i guess you could
surrender go down to your knees put your
hands up
apologize you could try to make a run
back to your car and hide
but you know maybe he'll just die you
know he doesn't care if police die he
really doesn't
democrats in general don't
they they it makes no difference to them
they do not care the the the lives of
police officers mean nothing to them
in fact in many cases they're happy when
cops die
which is why you know you remember i
said a couple months ago with officer
brian siknik
at the capitol who by the way we still
have not been told
what exactly you know how officer
sicknick died we were told by the media
immediately
that he was killed by a protester at the
capitol but
somehow even though he was murdered and
the media knew that right away
nobody's been charged with murdering him
we do know that that the other deaths
remember we were told
now i'm getting sidetracked a little bit
we were told by the media that
the riot on capitol hill was a deadly
riot and five people died
well the medical examiner in dc last
week finally came out
and admitted that three of the deaths
were medical emergencies
in fact well two were you know heart
conditions medical emergence people with
medical conditions
tragically died another person died of a
drug overdose
okay so those were counted in the tally
for five that's how they got to the
deadly riot
then another person ashley babbitt was a
homicide victim she was killed by a
capital police officer
and then we have brian singing we're not
being told anything about him the only
confirmed homicide
in the quote deadly riot was the
homicide that a that a protester was
a victim of
but any case brian sicknick you know um
however he died it's a terrible tragic
thing and
the democrats and the media are
mourning officer sicknick calling for
flags to be at half-staff talking about
the great service that he provided for
the community
talking about how they feel for his
family and his wife and his children
uh and of course yes that it is a
terrible tragedy
and the flag should be flawed at
half-mast and
we do feel terrible for his family the
difference is though
that the democrats saying that they
don't really mean it i don't believe and
i didn't believe then
for a second that they actually cared
about brian sicknick's death
because he's the only cop
that these democrats
i was running through a number of names
i could i just decided to go with
democrats
he's the only cop that they pretended to
care about
many cops have died over the last five
years
can you think of any other police
officer
that the majority of democrats you know
were publicly mourning
out of all the police officers who have
died
so on um on the rare occasion
when mourning a police officer's death
is politically expedient and convenient
for the democrats that's when they
pretend to care
but in every other case they couldn't
give it less of a dam
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content